in Argentina military historian Mike
Pavlik is investigating a series of
structures on a government restricted
island he learns they're connected to
Nazi scientists Ronald Richter invited
by the Argentinian President to run a
secret nuclear project you have to
wonder what could have happened if
Argentina in the 40s and 50s and 60s had
developed a nuclear program that just
changed the whole landscape of the world
[Music]
Pavlik exploration of the island reveals
empty structures and no visible evidence
of a complex nuclear facility
what's more bullet holes suggest that
work on the island comes to an abrupt
and violent end what was dr. Richter
working on specifically in how
successful was he never an official
disagree with our traditional ya tebya
zovut mantilla
y eso es hecho esto pero por yova
when I say most historians believe that
the Nazis never cracked nuclear fusion
it transpires that Richter was a con man
who scammed Argentinian President Juan
Peron out of millions of dollars
Richter was a chancer here's a Scholten
there was no way he was going to be able
to produce nuclear fusion pair on spent
an enormous amount of money that he
could ill afford on this project
he spent 62 million dollars Richter
wasn't the only Nazi in town torturer
dr. Josef Mengele and architect of the
Holocaust Adolf Eichmann also sought
refuge here
Pavlik presses local historian Abell
busty to name others were there more
important or notable Nazis that lived in
Bariloche after the war what he hears is
completely unexpected
do I feed him a turkey hang on a second
I might have missed the translation
Hitler in bariloche after the war was
over he just said si si si just a
colossal friend a widow syllable Aragorn
los Argentina so in the memory Luce a
survey D and Siri with the hey like a
hit or Maria parentheses